ladies and gentlemen i'm delighted
to be with you at this new economy forum
and i would like to thank you for the
invitation and
i would like to thank in particular mike
bloomberg
for his tireless efforts and generous
contribution
to the global response to this pandemic
as so often he has understood that
we are all in this together
my first message for you today is
that we will only end this pandemic if
we
fight it everywhere in the world
this crisis has shown us that global
public health
is the foundation of the world's
prosperity and security
and it is a prerequisite for recovery
and this is why the european union has
been leading
the global coronavirus response
since the beginning of the pandemic
we've joined forces
with global institutions with partner
countries
charitable foundations but also with
business
and civil society we brought together
more than 40 countries to raise 16
billion euros
and this to finance the development of
vaccines
tests and treatments for the whole world
developing a vaccine against covet 19
is one of the most pressing challenges
of our time
but just finding a vaccine is not enough
we must ensure that
everyone has access to it to end this
pandemic
and this is what the vaccine's pillar
in our global response the so-called
covex facility
aims to achieve safe vaccines
must be available for all whoever they
are
wherever they are whatever they can
afford
no middle or low-income country should
be left behind
and to the few countries hesitating to
join our efforts
i say this is as much a self-interest
investment
as it is a show of solidarity because
a global recovery is the only way
to reopen our economies to restart the
labor market
to repair supply chains and start
rebuilding
my second message is that we must
rebuild
our world better and what we do next
really matters over the next two years
governments around the world will spend
around 10
trillion euros for the recovery
the last time we had a recession
the world invested in piecing back
together
a broken system inequalities
and harmful emissions went up as did
commodity prices
and investments in fossil fuels we
cannot afford to make that same mistake
and as mike bloomberg has rightly said
this is about capitalizing on existing
market forces
not fighting them we need to use our
recovery stimulus to invest in the clean
and digital technologies of the future
to make our economies more resilient and
our societies and job markets
fairer and this
is the thinking behind europe's 1.8
trillion euro recovery package
our recovery plan we call it next
generation
eu will invest 37
in projects linked to our european green
deal
from clean hydrogen to housing
renovations you name it
and it will invest another 20 percent on
digital
from data to infrastructure and new
technologies
and this is how we can recover from this
crisis
and build a healthier and stronger world
for the next generation we can do it
if we do it together you can count on
europe to lead the way
thank you